New York is close to putting back what the terrorist took away.
Workers on the new tower rising near Ground Zero are erecting steel for the 100th floor, on their way to 104.
When 9/11/01 happened, I didn't know exactly what I could do.
And then within a year later, my daughter was born on 9/11/02,...
...and I got this huge thing that I wanted to have my daughter grow up knowing her birthday, what happened on that day,...
...and then knowing her father was like a hero.
He did something for it.
So I waited until her second birthday: on 9/11/04, I swore in.
And now I get to work here; it brings like another sense of pride.
I joined right out of high school; I shipped off in 2000...
...and the last thing I said to my family was, "Don't worry, it's not like anything is gonna happen."
And I had just arrived at my duty station when September 11 happened.
Being from New York, and going through what I've gone through, it's just an honor.
It's a point of personal pride to be here now,...
...working on any part of the World Trade Center.
Once the towers came down, I knew it was inevitable I was gonna be deployed.
They sent me out.
I came back.
Out of the whole city, this is where I wanted to work.
It's almost my way of, I guess, giving back in a way.
Being a soldier and going overseas, fighting for the country after it was under attack here...
...means a lot to work here at the World Trade Center because I know people who lost parents here,...
...siblings, friends; and I'm glad that I could be here, helping to bring back what we lost.